would you rather only hear one song for  the rest of your life or only watch one  TV show or movie song song on repeat  um Right Now Till I Collapse by Eminem  Signed Sealed Delivered by Stevie Wonder  I would never get tired of it that's a  great song that's like wedding  receptions like I'm never sick and tired  of it I would need like an oldies love  song for sure that those that's the  genre that you're not sick of yeah  September yeah that's a good one yes  always Earth Wind and Fire yeah  um yeah because the same TV show like we  need those we need TV shows or movies I  can't re-watch shows I like cannot do it  I have this weird analness to me  where I like it like anxiety think about  rewatching a show it's strange I don't  know how to explain it but I can't do it  well it's a bit boring knowing what  happens yeah but I feel weird yeah the  anxiety part is is different I have to  figure it out why